[Music]
there are a lot of remarkable games this
year so please note that the GameSpot
team put a lot of thought and
consideration and what we believe is the
best games of 2019 so here's a list the
top 10 games of the year from the very
passionate people who love them a lot
[Music]
don't shoot
when the original Resident Evil 2
released in 1998 it was heralded as a
masterpiece in survival horror however
all future resonable games Scents have
slowly been removing the creeping
zombies and going for a more action
route Resident Evil to 2019 is
noteworthy for being an excellent remake
of the original game but what truly
elevates it is how it uses modern tech
and design to improve upon the original
game zombie behavior is both
unpredictable and terrifying and mr. axe
is no longer relegated to simple
scripted sequences but now stalks you
relentlessly in a way that rivals even
nemesis and that is one of the few
reasons why Resident Evil 2 is one of
our favorite games of 2019
[Music]
round one beginning green countdown the
battle begins may the gods bless you I
don't fear anything can you say the same
apex Legends is a great battle royale
because respawn understands the niche
that it wants to fill everything about
this game is to better the understanding
of a team-based squad-based shooter the
shooting mechanics are great and the
sliding adds a nice speed to the combat
but better than anything else the ping
system the respawn mechanics and the
characters unique tactical and ultimate
abilities allow you to customize the
loadout of the team that you're trying
to form and do different types of
strategies during the game no other
battle royale is doing anything quite
like this and the fact that respawn kind
of jumped into this niche with
unprompted is really cool and it created
a game that was perfectly playable the
day it came out and that's why apex
legends is one of GameSpot's top 10
games of 2019
I'm coming free friend
protection winner decided you are the
apex champions I did it papa
I hope wherever you are you're cheering
for me
Sakura is one of our favorite games of
2019 because across the board from story
to characterization to gameplay
especially it's one of the most
fine-tuned expertly crafted exciting
games of the year
more importantly however it's a game
that challenges the players not just
through combat which is known to do but
through their expectations of what our
from software game is it's a reminder
that from software can still make
exciting scary and thought-provoking
games it's a game that explores death in
a meaningful way and that's something
that from software games have always had
the idea of life and death however this
is the first time it truly tackles that
head-on when all said and done though
Sakura has one of the sharpest combat
systems not only of the year but perhaps
overall time and it is that along with
the other story and characterization
stuff that makes it one of our favorite
games of the year
Shino vo there's a meticulous
anata originally
[Music]
[Music]
I'm dead they'll find it when the dead
stock I won't pass
where this was a play tale innocence is
a meticulously crafted adventure with
surprises around each and every corner
while there are many great things about
this game one of the standouts are its
characters by the time the credits roll
you really feel like you know amnesia
and Hugo and a plague tale isn't just a
pretty picture the further you get the
more involved the combat and puzzles get
but yen it is a really satisfying
action-adventure game with some really
cool puzzle elements due to these
reasons and many more a play tale is
easily one of our favorite games of 2019
[Music]
you
[Music]
how der waals is one of those games that
makes you see every other game
differently at any point while you're
exploring this handcrafted solar system
there are like four or five complex
mechanics happening right under your
feet whether it's gravity itself on each
individual planet or the orbit of that
meteor over there that's going to
eventually affect something you learn
later and also that learning itself is
just fun and it's rewarding and it's
impactful and you could beat the game
right away but it's structured so
cleverly to reflect something like
Groundhog Day or Majora's Mask and
you're going through these time loops
and the more you learn and the more you
understand this universe the more
dangerous the solar system becomes but
also just the more rewarding it is to
explore the way that it just sticks the
landing in this really far-out sci-fi
story makes it even better than it
already would be
[Music]
[Music]
one of the best things about Fire Emblem
three houses is how it brings all of its
different parts together to make
something bigger so you have the combat
which is excellent in the Fire Emblem
tradition turn-based tactical thinking
three four five steps ahead and then you
have the characters and I think one of
the best things three houses does is
slowly draws you into them bit by bit
with the different social levels you can
reach with them and as their professor
you're not romancing them you're
mentoring them you're getting to know
them as individuals and watch them grow
and that investment brings you much
closer to them and then you have the
school life stuff and that kind of
rounds it all together you're investing
in your students skills to make them
better in combat and on top of that
you're getting even more drawn in and
invested in the people that they become
and that's why three houses is so hard
to put down and undeniably had to be one
of GameSpot's top tech games of twenty
[Music]
here in Jerez home
[Music]
even just looking at control is enough
to fall in love with it it uses these
brutal edgy hard surfaces and this huge
building that's constantly transforming
in front of your eyes you're not a crazy
superhero you're just a person who's got
a little bit of levitation and a bit of
movement in the air but there's
something about doing that firing your
gun using like Jedi force powers it all
just works so well and flows almost
seamlessly and I know it's always good
to sort of have a resolution to stories
or really understand everything that's
happening in the world so you can feel
totally invested in it but control likes
to just dangle that one thing you can't
quite figure out right in front of you
it's a game that you just can't stop
thinking about and honestly if you want
you can kind of go on the internet and
really dive deep into subjects it plays
with we simply love control for all of
those reasons but because it's a game
that really resonated with us as a team
we honestly think it's one of the best
games of 2019
[Music]
about the job no it's gone three times
gone and never coming back you failed
you failed me
disco Elysium is one of the most unique
games I've ever played at its core it's
a detective RPG that happens to be
written
absolutely spectacularly it's
heartbreaking it's hilarious it's
completely off the wall and strange and
yet despite being pulled in so many
different directions it manages to tell
such a compelling and engrossing story
and also have a very intelligent
commentary about the way the world works
about politics and society but probably
most importantly psychology the things
that the game has to say about how our
pasts particularly the part of the
protagonist how his past defines him how
that's affecting his present and the
changes that he can make as he moves
forward into the game to decide who he
wants to be in the future and not only
interesting in the game but they're
interesting in a relatable sense
disco Elysium is so intelligent about
how it delivers its story and messages
it is a completely unmissable experience
[Music]
thanks for hearing me out and giving me
counsel the outer world isn't 2019 genre
defying game by any stretch that doesn't
mean it's still not an exceptionally
main game it's really really focused and
it does what it sets out to do extremely
well this is your world it's a world
where there are no black and white
everything seems great
every little quest every side quests
every main quest every approach to a
skirmish you could take on in a number
of different ways you can talk to AI you
can sneak your way through you can hack
your thing you can hit a thing you can
shoot a thing you can kill everyone you
know like this is the kind of game that
this is and it feels so liberating to
have so many options at your disposal
and the thing that really sticks with
you with long after you finish the game
is the writing of the characters every
NPC and especially the companions are so
well written not a single line of
dialogue feels wasted and that's why our
worlds despite being you know a genre
game really six with you and like what
really makes an impact it's something
that I wasn't expecting coming into it
but I'm really glad that I played it I
hope you do too
[Music]
once there was an explosion a bang which
set a planet spinning in that space
[Music]
once there was an explosion a bang which
gave rise to life as we know it
became the next explosion
after Metal Gear Solid 5 a lot of people
were very curious about what Hideo
Kojima was gonna be able to do with
death stranding and ultimately when we
got our hands on the game it proved to
be actually one of the most exceptional
games this year this is a game about
sort of forming connections with not
only the characters in the world but
also like other people who are playing
through the game sort of social strand
system everything you do makes a
difference like those little things kind
of contribute to this general cohesion
of the world that is just so endearing
it's so infectious there's something
about being able to feel like you're
serving and helping people out in the
world that makes death stranding an
exceptional experience not only just
because of how crazy and and odd it is
but how utterly optimistic it is
certainly because of those qualities
that this death stranding is one of our
favorite games this year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of these incredible games
we here at GameSpot decided that the
game of the year goes the second of
shadows died twice as tomorrow Hussein
put so eloquently across the board from
story to characterization to the
gameplay especially it's one of the most
fine-tuned expertly crafted exciting
games of the year when all is said and
done it has one of the sharpest combat
systems of all time if you're interested
in a more in-depth discussion as to why
we think suck arrow is the game of the
year make sure to check a video out
where tomorrow who's saying Michael
Hardy Lucy James and Jacob Dekker talked
all about it a link to that will be in
the description below in the meantime
let's see what 20/20 brings us anyways
thanks for watching until next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]